[Aplausos]
precisamos tornar os invisíveis visíveis
como professor de biologia do meu
cotidiano sempre teve visibilidade
quando eu procurava uma bactéria pelo
microscópio ou quando eu encontrava
apenas a pegada de uma onça nas minhas
saídas pela mata mas foi através de um
convite de alguns alunos que esse
conceito foi ampliado
eles tinham me convidado para participar
de um projeto de fotografia dentro de um
programa de iniciação científica que
duraria dois anos na escola naquele
momento tanto eu quanto eles tinham o
mesmo nível de conhecimento sobre
fotografia praticamente zero e tomamos
uma decisão e vamos aprender juntos com
transformar aquela vontade de fotografar
em algo concreto com um propósito
tínhamos praticamente um ano para
aproveitar o máximo de informações sobre
fotografia e foi o que fizemos
fotografamos conhecemos
estudamos triângulos erramos muito e
muitas vezes pensamos em desistir mas
nosso principal problema naquele naquele
momento era justamente encontrar um
propósito da fotografia história que a
gente queria contar
e para nos ajudar a isso nós queremos
pequenos desafios de fotografia semanal
onde desenvolvemos técnica composição
ampliavam o nosso olhar conheciam as
novas referências e principalmente
entendíamos quem era aquele grupo
durante esse processo foi ficando claro
que tipo de fotografia que a gente
queria pessoas estavam presente na
maioria das nossas fotos chegar no final
do ano da primeira fase
nós temos que entregar o objetivo do
projeto
são os muitos discutimos sobre sociedade
pessoas cidadania e ficava mais claro
para nós que a fotografia a nossa
fotografia podia ser voz para algumas
pessoas que talvez não tivessem outra
oportunidade de fazê la
sendo assim perguntas surgiram quem
seriam essas pessoas que histórias elas
teriam pra contar
aonde elas estariam
durante onze das nossas saídas nós
conhecemos o seu odorico uma pessoa
muito simples dona de um comércio local
muito escondido de acesso precário no
litoral de são paulo e entendendo o
desafio dele sim para mim sim permanecer
visível naquela sociedade surgiu a
pergunta fundamental para nós como
tornar pessoas invisíveis visíveis
naquele momento tínhamos encontrado
nosso propósito
nascia assim o projeto invisíveis
o ano seguinte foi um ano de muita busca
principalmente entender encontrar quem
seriam essas pessoas entre o contexto de
invisibilidade social elas estão
inseridas
nós não queríamos é seguir apenas o
contexto estereotipado e clássico de
invisibilidade como moradores de rua ou
coletores de lixo
nós entendíamos que as pessoas que não
que nós não enxergávamos era justamente
aquelas que nós não tínhamos referência
de conceito econômico social cultural
estético e pensando nisso nós
acreditamos que lá na escola não
encontraríamos essas pessoas
decidimos então percorrer 1.600
quilômetros sete cidades e encontrar
naquele segundo ano mais de 50 pessoas
mas a gente tinha uma regra simples
nunca durante essa fase as pessoas que
serão fotografadas seria fotografada sem
perceber que a gente chama na fotografia
de retrato roubado
a primeira coisa seria o encontro nos
encontraríamos essas pessoas onde quer
que elas estivessem e durante esse
encontro nós promoveremos uma escuta de
forma simpática sem julgamentos
entenderíamos aquela história e só
depois do encontro e da escuta empática
nós pediríamos a foto e assim a foto
tinha um ingrediente
além da imagem dessa forma nós pensamos
encontramos escutamos e fotografamos
muita gente que conhecemos muitas
histórias como por exemplo seu antônio
ferreira
um senhor que durante muitos anos
trabalhou no hospital psiquiátrico em
são paulo cuidando justamente de muitos
invisíveis e depois de aposentado ele
percorrer as ruas do bairro da liberdade
e conversava com todo mundo por ali
lutando contra sua própria visibilidade
conhecemos pessoas como esteve um
artista de rua que tinha muito em
transformar imagens em poesias a beleza
em movimento e muitas vezes dentro de
uma multidão ele se apresentava sozinho
sem que ninguém percebesse e pessoas
como dona marilda uma senhora muito
simpática que encontramos andando pela
avenida paulista
ela passava as tardes conversando com
todos e ela dizia que era o meio que ela
tinha encontrado para sair de casa e
mostrar quem ela era e assim como essas
pessoas foram passando pelas nossas
vidas muitas outras uma série delas e
quando imagem história se juntaram a nós
começamos a enxergar essas pessoas
foi um momento de conexão e pensamos que
talvez tenha chegado a hora de
apresentar essas histórias e
compartilhar essas experiências com
outras pessoas
o nosso ponto de partida foi a um de nós
começamos o trabalho na nossa escola
nós queremos uma exposição
para que todos pudessem entender aquilo
que a gente tinha feito durante esses
dois anos
e pensando naquelas pessoas que não
estavam na escola
nós fomos além e criamos um livro esse
livro contava um pouco de cada uma
dessas pessoas e das histórias que elas
carregavam e quando a gente achou que o
projeto estava no final já tinha chegado
no seu ponto máximo
nós fomos convidados por um seminário
educacional agora em 2016 a percorrer
nove cidades pelo brasil mostrando essa
história e as diversas outras histórias
que surgiram para educadores e também
inspiram desses educadores a usar a
fotografia como uma forma de linguagem
dentro da sala de aula
só que da mesma forma que a gente tinha
ido percorrer esses locais essas
capitais pelo brasil este ano
os jovens da nossa escola começaram a
querer participar do projeto a querer
também se expressar através da
fotografia e nós eu letícia renato
começamos a pensar de que forma que nós
poderíamos fazer isso e aí nós queremos
uma academia de fotografia com jovens do
ensino médio que queriam também contar a
sua história e essa academia ela servia
através de um processo de mentoria nós a
ajudaríamos esses jovens a descobrir
cris que história que eles poderiam
contar e durante esse ano nós tivemos
muitas surpresas
muitos trouxeram uma ampliação para nós
do conceito de visibilidade
algumas meninas pensar num projeto que
está na fase inicial ainda mais de
contar histórias de mulheres próximas a
elas e superação de vários tipos de
violência
um grupo de meninos surfistas que se
incomodam tanto com o estereótipo
negativo que colocam neles
com relação ao surf eles querem mostrar
através da fotografia que além da
prancha existe uma pessoa que está ali
que tem uma história além da prática e
muitas vezes esse estereótipo esse
estereótipo colocado esses adolescentes
os afastavam e criar um campo de
invisibilidade na própria
bola um outro grupo tem que estabelecer
uma relação milenar entre seres humanos
e cachorros mas numa situação de rua e
eles têm uma pergunta que vão tentar
responder através da fotografia
fantástico
será que os moradores de rua que possuem
cães sobrevivem mais na rua e será que
os cães que têm donos
moradores de rua também sobrevive mais e
por fim um dos projectos que têm um tema
que mais promove provoquem visibilidade
na escola uma aluna que trabalhar e da
voz para aquelas pessoas que por um
motivo de proteção acabam ficando
invisíveis porque sofrem bullying são
derivações do conceito de invisibilidade
que foram acontecendo durante esse ano
e aí a gente começou a se perguntar qual
foi um aprendizado para esse grupo que a
gente aprendeu com essa jornada a
primeira coisa foi nos enxergar cada um
de nós
descobriu durante esse processo
habilidades que nem conhecíamos o que
estavam adormecidas empatia comunicação
criatividade resiliência a ciência a
fotografia pra nós foi a ponte que cada
um construiu para enxergar as pessoas
a gente sabe que existem outros pontos
que podem ser construídas mas pra nós a
imagem é o caminho para chegar a elas
nós entendemos também que o conceito de
visibilidade é muito amplo e que basta a
gente querer se conectar com as pessoas
para entender as histórias e mais do que
isso
muitas vezes o invisível está do nosso
lado muito mais próximo do que a gente
imagina
essa dona marina ela é minha avó anos
ela luta contra o mal de alzheimer é uma
luta justa entre a clareza das suas
lembranças e escuridão do esquecimento
que a doença provoca eu tive que rodar
mais de 1.600 quilômetros para entender
eu estava ficando invisível dentro da
minha casa eu aprendi muito mais do que
eu ensinei esses jovens ensinaram o real
sentido da palavra educação educação
nada mais é do que construir pontes
junto com aqueles que querem atravessá
las e ser professor também é um ato de
transformar em visíveis e invisíveis
obrigado
[Aplausos]